el debate de la obligatoriedad toma
fuerza varios países dan un paso más
allá en su lucha contra el codi 19 y el
repunte de casos por la variante delta
es una constante
francia implementó una nueva normativa
donde será obligatorio la inoculación
para el personal de salud
después de la decisión del gobierno
siento que lo que tengo que hacer para
poder mantenerme activa y vivir
normalmente por otra parte me di cuenta
que debería hacerlo de todas maneras por
lo que está pasando con delta disculpa
se ve que está numerado en reino unido
pese a contar con más del 56 por ciento
de la población completamente vacunada
la variante delta llevó al parlamento a
tomar medidas entre ellas hacer
obligatoria la vacunación del personal
de asilos se estudia extender esta
medida a otros trabajadores en el sector
salud
en contraste países como españa portugal
y bélgica cuentan con altos niveles de
inoculación y la obligatoriedad no forma
parte de la agenda pública por el
momento por su parte en eeuu ciudades
como los ángeles ya requieren la
vacunación obligatoria para servidores
públicos
mientras en el país suben los casos de
kobe entre la población no vacunar
rivas tenemos eventos alrededor de
nuestra ciudad tenemos centro de
vacunación e incluso hemos ido puerta a
puerta ofreciendo vacunas y aún así
tenemos gente poniendo en peligro a
ellos y a los demás
lewis este tipo está realmente es una
pandemia de los no vacunados ese es
trulli plantea make up and access neira
mientras de estos países siguen
estudiando la obligatoriedad de la
vacuna en ciertos grupos en otros se
debate si estas medidas vulneran los
derechos fundamentales